neue diskussion über hartz 4 das
bundesverfassungsgericht stoppt zu
strenge strafen für arbeitslose die
nicht kooperieren
mit der afg reden oder nicht in einem
brief fordern 17 cdu funktionäre aus
thüringen mit allen demokratisch
gewählten parteien zu sprechen
die bundes partei nennt den vorstoß
tirre ist dass der kraftstoff der
zukunft die bundesregierung will
verstärkt auf wasserstoff setzen
aber die technologie hat noch ihre
tücken die nachrichten nicht erst heute
mit christian sievers und von uns allen
hier zu ihren 19 uhr nachrichten sport
nachher in der sendung mit kristin otto
in 15 minuten ein wegweisendes urteil
heute vom bundesverfassungsgericht es
geht um hartz 4 empfänger die ihren
pflichten nicht nachkommen und denen die
jobcenter daraufhin den geldhahn
zugedreht hatten
das geht so nicht sagen die
verfassungsrichter drastische kürzungen
sind mit dem grundgesetz nicht vereinbar
das gericht streitet damit direkt ein
und löst gleichzeitig eine neue debatte
über die grundsicherung generell aus wir
beginnen mit der juristischen seite und
günter neufeld die volle härte der
sanktionen yogalehrer bendel bekam sie
zu spüren vor jahren geriet er in eine
seelische krise wurde depressiv
reagierte nicht mehr auf kontaktversuche
des jobcenters irgendwann floss kein
geld mehr
das bedeutet dass man freunde nicht mehr
besuchen kann das ganze sozialleben
leidet darunter
man fühlt sich ausgeschlossen ja
abgewertet vielleicht auch durch den
staat abgewertet jedoch soll sich
niemand fühlen die menschenwürde müsse
gewahrt bleiben sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht doch das sei
bei den ganz harten sanktionen nicht der
fall
grundsätzlich jedoch dürfe der staat
menschen denen er helfe auch pflichten
auferlegen er kann sich auch dafür
entscheiden die verletzung dieser
pflichten zu sanktionieren in dem
leistungen vorübergehend gemindert
werden ein alleinstehender hartz iv
empfänger hat monatlich im schnitt rund
800 euro
bisher galt lehnte er eine zumutbaren
job ab verlor er 127 beim zweiten mal
innerhalb eines jahres 254 euro
beim dritten mal gab es kein geld mehr
alles befristet auf drei monate
doch gar keine zahlungen das geht zu
weit sagt das gericht und auch die
sanktion nach der zweiten ablehnung sei
zu hart zulässig bleibt der abzug der
bisher nach der ersten ablehnung fällig
war
kleine sanktionen also sind weiterhin
rechtmäßig gehalten kürzungen aber
entfallen mit sofortiger wirkung
es wird sich nicht so stark auf unser
geschäft auswirken weil die große große
anzahl der menschen die zu uns kommen
die wollen auch ihre arbeitslosigkeit
beenden die arbeiten auch mit die sind
kooperativ insbesondere geht es um
diejenigen die zum zweiten oder zum
dritten mal eine arbeit auf ablehnen und
das ist der sehr sehr sehr geringe teil
der menschen die wir küssen müssen hartz
4 empfänger bendel fühlt sich vom
bundesverfassungsgericht verstanden
die gesellschaft wird damit von angst
auf inklusion umgestellt den leuten wird
nicht ein stock in die speichen ihres
lebens gesteckt und deswegen bin ich
sehr positiv überrascht das ist heute
ein urteil in die richtige richtung
gehört wie der staat künftig auf
wiederholte verweigerungen reagieren
soll dazu muss die politik sich jetzt
neue regeln ausdenken
ja die politik ist also wieder gefragt
und da hat die diskussion auch schon
begonnen
der zuständige bundesarbeitsminister
hält das urteil für weise und ausgewogen
hubertus heil partei die spd will zum
teil radikale korrekturen am hartz iv
ihr programm das sie mitverantwortlich
macht für eine serie von wahlniederlagen
das heißt dass wir an dieser stelle eine
riesenchance haben einen
gesellschaftlich aufgeladenen konflikt
auch in dieser gesellschaft zu befrieden
weil das bundesverfassungsgericht heute
rechtssicherheit geschaffen hat sprechen
wir darüber noch mit seiner attacke aus
unserer rechts redaktion seiner guten
abend die richter haben das grundprinzip
von fördern aber eben auch fordern nicht
beanstandet aber der politik dann doch
einen rüffel gegeben
ja genau so ist es die richter haben mit
ihrem urteil ganz deutlich auch in
richtung politik gesagt die gesetze die
ihr gemacht habt
die verletzten die menschenwürde artikel
1 grundgesetz die verletzten das
sozialstaatsprinzip artikel 20
grundgesetz und sie war letzten diese
prinzipien so grundlegend und so
tiefgreifend dass sie sofort gehandelt
haben sie haben gesagt diese gesetze
werden sofort nicht mehr angewandt ab
heute ab
des urteils und sie haben selber fakten
geschaffen
das ist ungewöhnlich denn oft ist es so
dass die richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht erst mal dem
gesetzgeber den auftrag geben ein
verfassungskonformes gesetz innerhalb 1
23 jahren zu gestalten nicht so hier
hier haben sie heute direkt fakten
geschaffen weil sie sagt es ist so
dringend dass wir jetzt was tun müssen
die politik muss aber trotzdem natürlich
ihren auftrag jetzt erfüllen und etwas
ändern die diskussion geht schon los
wollten denn die richter das hartz4 auch
ganz grundsätzlich noch mal neu
diskutiert wird
diskussion ist sogar zu wenig sie wollen
das hat hier im grunde wieder so gedacht
wird wie es mal angedacht war nämlich
fördern und fordern
die begründung für dieses urteil heute
lesen sich sehr sehr spannend denn die
errichter haben ganz deutlich gesagt es
darf sanktionen geben es gibt kein im
grundgesetz verankertes bedingungsloses
existenzminimum ist darf an bedingungen
geknüpft werden aber nur bedingungen mit
augenmaß und die bedingungen die wir
bislang hatten die waren gerade nicht
mit augenmaß da gab es bedingungen der
gab es sanktionen die nicht dazu geführt
haben dass jemand wieder in den
arbeitsmarkt integriert wird aber nur
solche bedingungen sind zulässig und
deswegen ist das ein sehr deutliches
sehr klares urteil heute gewesen
sarah vielen dank wichtige thematik und
wer alles noch einmal kompakt nachlesen
möchte was das hartz4 urteile im
einzelnen bedeutet und welche
auswirkungen die entscheidung für
betroffene hat dem empfehlen wir unsere
online seite wie immer heute.de
nächstes thema der ausstieg der tramp
regierung aus dem pariser
klimaschutzabkommen steht bevor
jetzt will die eu mit einzelnen
us-bundesstaaten und städten an der
einhaltung der klimaziele arbeiten
gestern hatte die us-regierung ihre
ankündigung des abkommens offiziell bei
der ihre aufkündigung des abkommens
offiziell bei den vereinten nationen
eingereicht
aus formalen gründen wird der ausstieg
allerdings erst in einem jahr wirksam
mit den linken oder der afg
zusammenarbeiten wieder noch hatte die
cdu beschlossen vor kaum einem jahr
dann aber kam das wahldebakel in
thüringen und jetzt ein brief dort von
17 parteifunktionären man wolle nicht
koalieren aber mit allen sprechen also
auch mit der
fd und die bundes-cdu sie schäumt irre
sagt generalsekretär paul signac denn
die afg versuche das land zu spalten
spaltet sie nun die cdu aus thüringen
daniela sonntag als der brief kam habe
sie ihn mit wohlwollen gelesen sagt cdu
landrätin martina schweinsburg
ausgereizt und auch sie können das so
unterschreiben ja zu gesprächen und nein
zu berührungsängsten mit der thüringer
fdp anhang zu ihrer auffassung die
fdp-fraktion von neun personen mit denen
man sehr vernünftig und sachlich und
ergebnisorientiert zusammenarbeiten kann
kurzfristige interview absagen kein
rückruf die 17 unterzeichner wissen dass
sie eine grundsatzdebatte losgetreten
haben ergebnisoffene gespräche fordern
sie reden womöglich sogar kooperation
für viele in der thüringer cdu ist das
ein tabubruch besonders wegen afg chef
bion hüppe cdu landrat werner henning
aus dem eichsfeld ist entsetzt über
solche gedanken spielt ist eine schande
sich mit den stimmen einer hecke afd
wählen lassen ob im geheimen oder in
einer offenen weiße geht nicht dass
solche ideen überhaupt diskutiert werden
in der cdu-führung unverständnis das
kooperationsverbot mit der afg gelte
weiter also diese ganze debatte ist irre
es geht hier um grundsätze und von
unseren grundsätzen von unseren werten
herr verbietet sich jeder gedanke
darüber mit der hfg zusammenzuarbeiten
die zerreißprobe der cdu auch ein
ergebnis des thüringer wählerwillens der
richtungsstreit wird im land heftig
diskutiert mit dieser partei kann man
nicht zusammen arbeiten
das sind also anzunehmende leute die die
politik wohl genau wie jeder an bord bei
auch keine koalition mit der afg die
thüringer cdu parteiführung hat allen
spekulationen heute erneut eine absage
erteilt morgen vormittag kommt die
fraktion im landtag zusammen es gibt
wohl viel gesprächsstoff
vor den toren der eu bahnt sich wieder
ein problem an seit monaten steigt die
zahl der migranten die ihren weg aus der
türkei nach mitteleuropa suchen auf der
sogenannten balkan route stranden viele
von ihnen in einem lager im bosnischen
bhc hausen dort unter menschenunwürdigen
bedingungen kein strom kein fließendes
wasser und jetzt kommt der winter
topalov dschungel nennen die insassen
das camp mag es ist ausschließlich für
männer gut 700 sind es vor allem aus
pakistan afghanistan manche aus syrien
hier sieht es nicht so aus wie auf einer
müllhalde es war mal eine kaum sauberes
trinkwasser kaum strom verdreckte
toiletten alles ist improvisiert
wir haben auf steinen geschlafen erst
vor zwei tagen haben sie uns denken
gegeben
davor hatten wir keine decke nichts als
unwürdige nord kritisiert die
europäische union das camp in einem
waldgebiet in dem noch landminen aus dem
bosnien-krieg liegen laut eu gab es
deswegen auch kein geld für das camp die
stadt hat es allein finanziert der
bürgermeister fühlt sich im stich
gelassen auch vom eigenen staat
er droht nun damit die zahlungen
einzustellen wir haben bislang die
versorgung geleistet einen platz zur
verfügung gestellt das rote kreuz das
finanziert wird aus dem budget der stadt
mihatsch hat wasser und essen verteilt
jetzt sagten wir genug wir werden das
nicht länger tun
das dürfte die zustände noch weiter
verschlimmern
krankheiten wie krebs breiten sich aus
in die zelte regnet es hinein und die
mitarbeiter des roten kreuzes warnen vor
dem winter wir wollen den menschen
helfen es ist sehr schwierig für uns sie
zu sehen wie sie frieren ohne schuhe
keine kleidung wenn jetzt der schnee
kommt dann geht nichts mehr
das spiel nennen die männer den versuch
über die grenze in die eu zu gelangen
doch wer von der polizei aufgegriffen
wird landet wieder hier
selbst wenn putsch abgeschlossen wird
weiß niemand was dann mit diesen
menschen geschehen soll
ganz anderes thema jetzt die neue
drogenbeauftragte der bundesregierung
daniela ludwig fordert ein vollständiges
werbeverbot fürs rauchen
gerade junge menschen ließen sich davon
beeinflussen sagte sie bei der
vorstellung des drogen und suchtberichts
in berlin zwar rauchen immer weniger
jugendliche der anteil der raucher hat
sich in den letzten jahren fast halbiert
und auch bei den jungen erwachsenen geht
der trend in diese richtung
doch gleichzeitig wird die e-zigarette
immer beliebter sowohl unter den
jugendlichen als auch unter den jungen
erwachsenen gibt es immer mehr noch die
zigarette ist ein wellness produkt wir
wissen nicht wie schädlich sie auf lange
sicht wirklich ist
deswegen darf sich beworben werden
deswegen auf die bewerbung auch schon
gar nicht und jugendlichen sich richten
und deswegen ist es nicht ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir kein tabak werbeverbot
dem sack lässt wirklich zu machen uns
nord komplett
eine offene debatte will die
drogenbeauftragte wenn es um die frage
geht ob der besitz und konsum von
cannabis erlaubt werden soll
auch dabei müsse der gesundheitsschutz
von jugendlichen eine zentrale rolle
spielen
im kanzleramt gestern abend wieder mal
ein auto gipfel das zeigt schon wie
wichtig diese industrie ist und wie
drängend deren zukunftsfragen wie können
elektroautos in der autonation
deutschland durchstarten
die antwort des gipfels ein
milliardenschweres förderprogramm
so soll etwa die kaufprämie für e-autos
bis 2025 verlängert und erhöht werden je
nach modell können kunden nun mit bis zu
6000 euro rechnen
bezahlt jeweils zur hälfte vom staat und
von der industrie und in den nächsten
zwei jahren soll es 50.000 neue
öffentlich zugängliche ladestationen
geben
politik und industrie setzten also voll
auf elektrische antriebe habe der strom
dafür aber aus batterien oder aus
brennstoffzellen kommen soll darüber
gibt es unterschiedliche meinungen
die brennstoffzelle ist gut erforscht
einfach gesagt erzeugt strom aus
wasserstoff und sauerstoff und treibt so
einen elektromotor an den wasserstoff zu
erzeugen benötigt aber sehr viel energie
es ist teuer und produziert derzeit noch
viel co2 es ist also noch ein weiter weg
wieder an der posten zeigt das jahr 2000
es gab noch regelmäßig große abendshows
mit thomas gottschalk und bald schon
würde es so schien es sieht sauber aus
von wasserstoff angetriebene autos geben
was aus dem auspuff kam konnte man sogar
trinken
die technik gab es schon damals viel
weiter ist man seither nicht unsere
zielrichtung ist klar wir wollen nicht
nur bei der wasserstofftechnologie
klimaschutz und energiewende
voranbringen wir wollen dass deutschland
bei den wasserstoff technologie die
nummer 1 in der welt wird wie dazu war
heute wenig konkretes zu hören bis ende
des jahres soll er eine strategie stehen
derzeit ist japan technologisch weit
vorn in deutschland gibt es etwa bislang
gerade 70 tankstellen bundesweit im
frühjahr sollen es rund 100 sein
das kernproblem noch verschlingt die
herstellung von wasserstoff unmengen an
energie sinnvoll wird die technologie
daher erst wenn grüner strom in viel
größeren mengen vorhanden wäre wir gehen
davon aus dass man erst dann sinnvoll
wasserstoff erzeugen kann wenn wir die
gesamte stromproduktion zu etwa 70 bis
80 prozent auf erneuerbare energien
umgestellt haben
damit können wir etwa im jahr 2040
rechnen auch für künstlichen flugzeug
kraftstoff ließe sich wasserstoff nutzen
ebenso als klimaneutrale rohstoff in der
chemieindustrie oder für
umweltfreundlichere stahlerzeugung aber
der ja zu wasserstoff sagt der muss auch
ja sagen zu windkraftanlagen weil die
dann helfen diesem wasserstoff wirklich
herzustellen die deutsche industrie
forderte unterdessen man müsse dann beim
bau erster klimaneutraler
wasserstoffanlagen finanziell entlastet
werden konkret durch billigeren strom
eine befreiung von der eeg-umlage das
jedoch wollte altmaier heute nicht zu
sagen nur so viel man werde die bitte
prüfen
also noch eine reihe von offenen und
fragen das gilt auch für den fußball
diese woche es gibt einiges zu erzählen
die trainersuche zum beispiel beim fc
bayern münchen läuft auf hochtouren
während interims trainer hansi flick für
sportliche erfolgserlebnisse sorgen soll
zwei siege binnen vier tagen in der
champions league und im
bundesliga-topspiel eine klare ansage
der neue chef und sein co trainer hansi
flick und hermann gerland jetzt die
sportlich verantwortlichen beim
rekordmeister nach der entlassung von
niko kovac stehen aber vor allem die
spieler im fokus die hauptverantwortung
tragen jetzt wir spieler
wir müssen uns jetzt am riemen reißen
ich sage mal es gibt für keinen mehr
ein alibi oder irgendwie 'ne ausrede
flick hat bereits heute verkündet auf
wen er gegen piräus und dann auch gegen
dortmund vertraut
ich will natürlich auch eine mannschaft
haben die auf das spiel am samstag auch
schon schon eingespielt ist und deswegen
wird auch harvey martinez spielen
das könne nicht kann ich ihnen sagen
auch thomas müller wird spielen offen
wie lange flick cheftrainer bleibt
ajax-trainer ten hat jedenfalls hat
heute seinen verbleib in amsterdam bis
sommer bestätigt spiel eins nach kovac
die bayern wollen ab jetzt wieder dem
gegner kopfschmerzen bereiten ja und
borussia dortmund steht vor dem
liga-gipfel bereits heute abend in der
königsklasse unter erfolgsdruck gegen
inter mailand mit der gut machen nach
dem 0 2 vor zwei wochen um die chance
aufs achtelfinale zu wahren
auch bvb trainer lucien favre packt an
alles muss passen für das spiel gegen
inter mailands nur steht hinter dem
einsatz des kapitäns ein fragezeichen
marco reus hat fußprobleme resultierend
aus der partie gegen wolfsburg bis jetzt
weiß ich nicht
über macht ob es möglich ist dass er da
ist
wir werden sehen nachher sollte
ausfallen dürfte julian brandt ins
zentrum rücken dort die offensive
beleben
tore müssen her das spiel unbedingt
gewonnen werden nach der
hinspielniederlage ging
sein land ist der bvb unter zugzwang wir
haben viel viel vor noch in der
champions league deswegen wollen wir das
spiel definitiv gewinnen heute mailand
samstag die bayern eine interessante
woche für den bvb auf dem punkt kann ich
besser sagen danke christian wetter noch
im norden regnet zweiter im süden kann
auch mal die sonne scheinen tatsächlich
zu den details gleich gunther tiersch
dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute schon
ein mit den kollegen claus kleber um 21
uhr 45 morgen gibt es uns wieder punkt 7
für heute danke fürs zuschauen und ihnen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einige zuschauer im norden wird es auch
morgen wieder nass werden heute schon
den ganzen tag über geregnet dieses
regengebiet wird in den nächsten 24
stunden langsam nach süden voran kommen
wenn dieses tief hier durchgezogen ist
da kommt die luft aus norden ist ein
bisschen kühler aber es lockert an der
nordsee dann auch wieder auf heute nacht
regnet es aber noch im norden auch im
süden haben wir anfangs noch ein paar
schauer später nebelfelder und am
kühlsten wird es am alpenrand mit null
grad sonst bleibt es deutlich milder und
morgen haben wir dann in norddeutschland
immer noch den regen anfangs zumindest
aber im laufe des vormittags wird der
regen an der nordsee dann schon aufhört
und es kann hier und da ein bisschen
auflockern bei diesen ja mäßigen
nordwind gleichzeitig wird es dann in
der mitte deutschland anfangen zu regnen
also hier über der mitte während es im
süden anfangs noch freundlich ist
schauer sind erstmal selten zum
nachmittag hin wird auch dort stärker
bewölkt und es geht los mit dem schauern
der wind weht dabei frisch aus südwest
bis west die temperaturen eher ein
bisschen niedriger es wird kühler also
sechs bis zehn grad höchstens mal im
osten in der lausitz um die 12 grad und
am donnerstag und freitag wird es immer
wieder mal im westen und auch im süden
regnen in norddeutschland sich
freundlicher aus und zum sonntag zum
samstag wird es kühler
und dann kann es auch mal im süden
schneiden oberhalb von 600 bis 800
metern
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut